we are here with george oliphant from
george to the rescue helping us with a
special uh design drew over on speckling
and he's teaching us how to empower
ourselves and take business into our own
hands exactly yeah you can do it
everyone can do it which is not hard
okay so before the break we backed
we spackled yep we scraped we let it dry
now what do we do okay so now what
you're gonna do is you would sand where
the where your where your repair is sand
it all down this is going to dry it
sands off really nicely you get it nice
and smooth
and then after you sand it you are going
to uh you're going to prime it
bravo beautiful beautiful like a pro
thank you then you prime it okay um so
it's already actually so these i think
have already been primed this has
definitely been primed this one is not
but that's all right okay the importance
to priming that is a very important step
a lot of times people will skip the
priming step do not do that because if
you ever notice you're sitting in a room
and you look at a wall and even though
it's all the same color you can see that
there was once a patch there yeah that's
because somebody didn't prime it that's
called flashing
and so if you prime it that way the
paint will all adhere equally to your
repair and to the wall i haven't been
primed well
no that looks like there's a little
prime on there is some prime on there
primer primer you have prime
do you guys anybody here ever paint
without priming i'm so guilty of it
because i'm like painted white what and
then paint is that double the work
there's a lot of options out there some
compounds come with primer in it okay
some paints come with primer in it but
it's always a good idea to prime it and
then yes you just roll it out now
there's times where you can use a brush
and there's times where you want to use
a roller when you're on a wall you want
to use a roller that's going to give you
a much more even finished product that
way you don't get like brush marks or
anything brushes are great obviously if
you're working in corners or if you're
working on trim or book bookshelves or
something like that but for this wall
yeah and then just roll it out this is
exactly what i look like too but
look at that i would give it maybe one
more thing we'll let it dry and then get
it with a second coat and i am so
inspired oh no no my second coat's not
going that's all right that's all right
you're good you're good don't press too
hard let the let the tool do the work
that's another problem sometimes with
people with rollers they push real hard
let the roller just roll and you'll be
good to go that way you don't get roller
marks you don't get brush marks what do
you do to get paint on your blazer oh no
oh that's a whole different type of
rescue drew's so excited you can take
this out oh god i gloom again let me add
it
let me add it don't touch it okay okay
okay okay um well gosh george everything
i do is like way too much and i did no
no you did great you did fantastic all
right is it okay i will say we learned
so much today it's i can't even see the
repair you fix it it's gone you made it
here
you did a good time you guys are
impressed
yes yes yes george can you please come
back i would be honored to thank you
there's so much we have to learn from
you there's a lot to fix in people's
houses i'm happy to help any time
there's a lot to fix in life there's a
lot to fix in life yeah well thank you
george oliver so much george for the
rest
and the new season will premiere on
march 26th on nbc
[Music]